in the 70s you've created the tech
typesetting system together with meta
font language for font description and
computer modern family of typefaces that
has basically defined the methodology in
the aesthetic of the countless research
fields right math physics well beyond
design and so on okay well first of all
thank you I had I think I speak for a
lot of people in saying that but
question in terms of beauty there's a
beauty to typography that you've created
and yet beauty is hard to quantify right
how does one create beautiful letters
and beautiful equations like what what
what so I mean perhaps there's no words
to be describing you know be described
in the process but so the great Harvard
mathematician Georg deeper cut wrote a
book in the 30s called the aesthetic
measure where he where he would have
pictures of bases and underneath would
be a number and this was how beautiful
the base was and he had a formula for
this and and he actually also right over
brought about music and so he could he
could you know so I thought maybe I
would part of my musical composition I
would try to program his algorithms and
and you know so that I would I would
write something that had the highest
number by his score well it wasn't quite
rigorous enough work for a computer to
to do but anyway that people have tried
to put numerical value on beauty but and
he did the probably the most serious
attempt and and George Gershwin's
teacher also wrote two volumes where he
talked about his method of of composing
music but but you're talking about
another kind of beauty and beauty and
letters and letter of elegance and
whatever that yeah butcher is right so
so
and so that's the beholder as they say
but kinder striving for excellence in
whatever definition you want to give to
beauty then you try to get as close to
that as you can somehow with it I guess
I guess I'm trying to ask and there may
not be a good answer
what loose definitions were you're
operating under with the community of
people that you're working on oh the
loose definition I wanted I wanted it to
appeal to me to me I meet you personally
yeah that's a good start
yeah no and it failed that test went
when I got volume two came out with this
with the new printing and I was
expecting to be the happiest day of my
life and and I felt like a burning like
how angry I was that I opened the book
and it it was in the same beige covers
and and but but it didn't look right on
the page the number two was particularly
ugly I couldn't stand any page that had
a two in this page number and I was
expecting that it was you know I spent
all this time making measurements and I
see and I had looked at toughens in
different different ways and I hate I
had great technology but but it did you
know but I but I wasn't done I had I had
to retune the whole thing after 1961
has it ever made you happy finally oh oh
yes
or is it appointing oh no no and so many
books have come out that would never
have been written without this I just
didn't just draw is just it's a joy but
I can but now I I mean all these pages
that are sitting up there I I don't have
a it if I didn't like him I would change
him like that's my no nobody else has
this ability they have to stick with
what I gave them
yes so in terms of the other side of it
there's the typography so the look of
the of the type and the curves and the
lines what about the spacing what about
the
facing because the white space no it
seems like you could be a little bit
more systematic about the layout or oh
yeah you can always go further III I
didn't I didn't stop at point eight I
stopped I stopped about point nine eight
seems like you're not following your own
rule for happiness or is no no I
there's okay that of course there's this
is the Japanese word wabi-sabi or
something that where the the most
beautiful works of art are those that
have flaws because then the person who
who perceives them as their own
appreciation and that gives you or more
satisfaction or so on but but i but no
no with typography I wanted it to look
as good as I could in in the vast
majority of cases that and then when it
doesn't then I I say okay that's two
percent more work for the wrote for the
author but but I didn't want to I didn't
want to say that my job was to get to
hundred percent with and take all the
work away from the author that's what I
meant by that
you